[Music]
on today's show we talked to an
extraordinary mother of two who's
wondering am i too old to heal for my
trauma
we also talk to a mom whose daughter is
getting out of a psychiatric hospital
and she wants to know the steps she can
take to love her daughter the best when
she gets home it's a good show stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
everybody this is john with the dr john
delaney show
man it's so good
well i was gonna say it so good to see
you but i can't see you and i was gonna
say so gonna talk to you
i'm talking to you i guess this is a
one-way conversation feel free to talk
back to me wherever you happen to be if
you're walking through target
and you've got your
this is not a target audience actually
this is more of a uh
i don't know what kind of audience is
this this is more of a gas station
audience right
just kind of rolling out in the buckies
or the flying what is that flying uh
flying j flying j this is a flying j if
you are cruising the flying j aisle
right now for what flavor zinger best
represents you
and what slurpy combo you're gonna be
all over
listen feel free to talk back to me
actually if you're in bucky's there's
everybody's talking to everybody in
there so it's cool
and now i can't even tell cause i got
those earpieces and i don't know who's
talking to me who's not it's it's just
setting me all off but a couple of
important things this is a big
announcement on the dr john dolone show
this is huge
my little brother who rules by the way
if you want to know like
i'm not i'm the quiet one in my family
that's me being honest like at
thanksgiving i'm the guy that's like hey
can we just tone it down a bit this is a
lot
my brother's awesome and he sent me this
hilarious meme yesterday here's what it
says
says i wonder if the people paying 300
for a colon cleanse even know about taco
bell's 4.99 deal
so i saw that and i laughed real hard i
didn't expect it it made me super laugh
and then
on the internets
this extraordinary woman i don't know
who it is i was gonna say slid into my
dms but that's a bad thing right i can't
say that she didn't slide into my dm she
sent me a direct message
is that the more polite way to say that
i think so oh my gosh i was born in the
wrong century sent me this incredible
photo here
and it's of a sign
of a free advertisement to this company
it's a colonoscopy company called let it
go
and sometimes i get down on the united
states and sometimes i get down on just
the state of the world
if you have a colon cleanse company and
it's called let it go
we should all take that as a sign as
things are gonna be okay i think we're
gonna be all right i think we're coming
out of this the dorito taco first time
i've been into the dorito taco i thought
we're all gonna be okay
like the most extraordinary engineering
minds on planet earth came up with this
we are gonna die young but we're gonna
be all right you picked a good day to
share this with kelly being out cause
she would have been thrown up by now
with all this kelly's not out hey what's
up kelly
hey
your beard looks awesome
i don't haven't seen you wear a hat in a
while
dude it's all how do you say that not
this is gonna be a different show
because kelly's not here the are you
answering the phone when you call people
this is austin by the way austin's on
the uh on the internets today
and uh zach h and the faux hawk is still
figuring out over there on on the
screens he's like looks like he's
launching a ship at nasa and really he's
just hitting a record button but
whatever we all overstayed our our
expertise but austin when you answer the
phone are you saying like hey this is
kelly
no it's just welcome to the john daloni
show oh it's not near as fun the next
caller when you call them you have to be
like hey this is kelly
i uh i have
all i have the first 18 covids not 19
but i got one through 18.
that'd be excellent don't do that that's
probably sorry to everybody about that
joke is that bad it's too soon sorry
i never had any kovitz 1 through 18.
you did didn't you james for being so
smart sometimes
right hey uh i'm gonna read another poem
or two
all right
a poem
commemorating the upcoming one-year
anniversary of the show by a grateful
listener that is over but we're still
going to read anyway
there was once a doctor named john
evidently in this poem i'm dead we'll
continue
there was once a doctor named john the
dave ramsey show he was on his
credentials he had a pot full and his
advice it was quite thoughtful
now his own show john speaks upon
this is phenomenal i might get this one
tattooed on my arm that's fantastic
good work that one had a limerick
quality about it yeah and it like
circled back on the original rhyme
i don't know it's from rick
rick outstanding uh you should be a
hip-hop artist and we'll just do one
more this one's in a
fancy pants envelope oh well that's not
a
that got weird let's do another one
who's this one from stephen
come on man
here's his poem
roses are red
violets are blue
dr john dolone shows best
and kelly's commentary is too
i'll add my rhyme boo
final line thanks for all that you do
do that was awesome i added that i did
notice kelly writing a lot of random
postcards and letters and mailing them
her desk is by yours is she just like
writing lots of letters and putting them
in the mail
her annual review is coming up everybody
and she's really sweating it so
um most of us work harder what kelly
does is just write herself letters
dude one day i'm gonna be sick you know
just gonna do the show without me the
trash we're all gonna talk about it's
gonna be so great yeah kelly's out not
feeling good um she does not have the
the c-109 but she's not feeling good and
we do miss her but we're glad we got
austin with the beard in there it's good
to see you man i would grow a beard like
that but i am physically unable to all
right let's take our first call let's go
to
jennifer in birmingham what is up
jennifer
hey dr john how are you taking my call
i'm doing um i just want you to know too
that your show i'm sure lots of people
tell you this but your show does make a
difference and it's made me take like a
long hard look at my life well number
one
nobody tells me that so thank you
even my wife is like can you just let's
mow lawns let's have a family lawn
bowling business um your show's terrible
so thank you so much um that really
means a lot to me and
the
you're the one doing the work and so i'm
proud of you for
like man leaning in and making some hard
changes in your life um talk directly in
your phone cause i wanna make sure i
don't miss this um what's going on in
your world
okay um i'm gonna make it short and
sweet or cut right to the point um i
grew up in an abusive household um i
heard obviously by listening to you
already i've heard about your aces scale
so i'm a six on that and now um 15 years
out of that you know leaving that home
and everything i'm now a single mom of
two great girls and um my question to
you is is it too late for me to heal
from my
childhood drama oh what an awesome
question jennifer did you know almost
nobody asks that question
that's incredible good for you
um
i can answer that question but for the
sake of radio can we dig into some of
the past stuff are you okay with that
sure yeah sure um
the simple answer is yes and i'm so glad
that you asked that absolutely one
million percent yes
um so tell me about your childhood
um well i had um my biological father
was absent so basically from you know
most of my first couple years it was
just me and my mom and while she was
trying to get her life together you know
i was bounced around at different family
homes and then she met a guy married him
he
adopted me and
they have a very volatile relationship
there were
obviously
there was physical abuse verbal abuse my
mom didn't really stand up for herself
so as the only child for almost the
first 10 years of my life i felt the
need to insert myself because you know
that's my mom she shouldn't take that
and then um there were some times where
i don't know if she meant to or not i
guess you don't know if anyone does she
had some suicide attempts and so it was
just
it was a long 15 years and then i ended
up leaving um
halfway through my senior year of high
school and went to live with my
grandparents and that kind of ripped it
all wide open because you know we don't
um kind of like calling you today we
don't air laundry or skeletons in public
and most people wouldn't have known if
um i guess if they just didn't really
really know us or anything i guess we
were good at keeping our business in the
house
wow wow and so what happened in your
marriage
um
honestly i
maybe i wasn't mentally
prepared for it does that make sense um
i ended up i don't think i don't think
any of us are mentally prepared for
marriage i don't know i think i um we we
got pregnant before we got married and
so i think we got married trying to do
the right thing and um i've listened to
some of your other shows and i could
kind of i kind of you know in my 30s now
you know he and i are civil we've gone
great at co-parenting we've been
divorced for um you know seven or eight
years now it's just we did not um it was
kind of like having an extra child and i
i had just enough for me and my kids and
that's not really an excuse i know i've
played a part in it but um i don't know
i guess my focus too and that sounds
awful too at the time i wasn't focused
on being the best spouse ever i was just
from my childhood on i just if i ever
had kids i wanted to make sure that i
was better than the hand i was dealt and
we had a rough go and i didn't want to
be one of those people that stayed in a
miserable marriage like my parents are
25 years later
gotcha gotcha
um
and thanks for sharing that so
give me give me a rundown of the last
six seven years
what's up in line um
well it was um kind of i guess getting
divorced kind of added stress but it was
also a release at the same time you know
i'm standing on my own two feet i have
two great girls they're now um both at
that preteen puberty age which has been
really fun um but like i said i've
worked really hard you know even you
know getting pregnant in college my kids
are 11 months apart so you know i did
really good planning that as well but i
i never took time off you know i
finished college i have a full-time job
i'm a manager i do great my kids see
that i work hard um
i am
recently diagnosed with add which makes
sense a lot personally
yeah exactly exactly and i got bored um
you know a couple years into my divorce
and decided i needed a second degree
because you know school and work and
everything wasn't enough i needed
something else to like keep me going so
they've seen me you know work hard for
everything i do that's important i try
to make their world as safe and calm as
possible um but
i guess
my grandma died a few years ago and i
guess that's kind of random but she was
my rock in the world you know she knew
all of the pain i was going through and
i could come to her there was no
judgment she was my person in my life
who you know told me she was proud of me
told me she loved me there was no
manipulation or anything else or i never
worried about going you know to her
house or like you know my house i did
everything i could to get out of it and
so um but she passed away a few years
ago and that was kind of a um
i don't know it was like something
clicked and i realized i didn't have
anyone to lean on anymore and um my
parents are still in my life but i draw
very hard boundaries and even when i try
to reach out you know medical issues
come off things with my kids other stuff
they just it's just a repeated
disappointment if that makes sense so i
have this gap in my life and
growing up i was you know in survival
mode constantly so it didn't really
affect me now but the further i get away
from that um the more it tries to
resurface so you know i my only tool
apparently in my tool belt is this rusty
old shovel because i bury everything now
every time it rains in my life a little
it's just someone coming to the surface
yeah so i'm trying to find healthy ways
without you know dropping a jug of milk
you know on the floor and then just
having a meltdown because that's not
realistic and that's not why i'm
you know having a meltdown yes
so
first and foremost you were so brave
what i mean
like i'd hug you i'd ask you but i'd hug
you if you were sitting here like
um you've been through it
and you're working so hard
it's it's so admirable how you are cont
you're standing at the helm of that ship
and you are leaning on it to turn the
thing around
so hard and you have been for so long
and it's admirable how you're using your
strength is so good
um
so you said you've been in flight since
when you were a little kid just
constantly on the go and what i would
tell you is after talking to you for
three minutes
your um
your engine runs hot
is that fair
and so i wrote down a few things you
said um
you're providing a safe calm world for
your daughters
i'm just going to make some guesses here
does your safe and calm come through
organization
and
cleanliness and routine planning
yes planning i i spring clean 15 times a
year where people probably think i'm
compulsive but my parents were also
hoarders too and it's just
i have to have my i'm not like a mean
controlling person i just have to know
what's going on for us to you know flow
okay so number one
you're still in fight or flight and you
have been for how old are you 31
32 yeah 32 so you have been for about 30
years
okay
and in counseling we say we call it
leakage which is
you can deal with this stuff or it will
deal with you and it usually picks the
most inopportune times
like you say like it's just i'm making
cereal for my daughter and i drop the
milk
and all of a sudden six minutes later
i'm on the floor and i can't breathe and
my i have an 11 year old looking at me
thinking like asking what happened to
mommy right or you're prepping for
um a work presentation or you are
all are you always almost late are you
always on time
um i try to be on time say i knew it you
were almost always late
we yeah
we we're pushing you know we're pushing
down the barrel which it doesn't help
that my job is a little flexible so it's
not that i have to punch the clock as
long as i'm there within like a ballpark
time
let's keep it going because now you're
making me feel like um i'm uh like
i'm smarter than i am and then when
you're at work sometimes you have entire
blocks where you just start off in a
space or you will youtube down a rabbit
hole
um and then
i will in a few hours after your kids go
to bed you will get more done and it
will be outstanding work
and then you guess like
bosses
and then you get mad at yourself like
why can't i just do this during the day
it's so ridiculous and then you loop
back and then the whole thing starts
over you are
um
here's my guess my guess is the little
girl in you stood between mom and an
abusive guy and she tried to fight
and she learned at an early age
that
her muscles were little and her voice
was little and she saw what happens when
her mom who's the model for a woman in
her life stands up to a guy it ends
really badly
and
you shifted from fighting to running
and
when you have a traumatic childhood when
you have a traumatic adulthood which a
divorce is i know it happens all the
time and we un we under appreciate how
heavy it is
um even like you said you can finally
breathe for the first time you stood up
on your own two feet but you actually
anchored to somebody else and then that
somebody else passed away you realized
oh no i'm totally untethered um
then we just start running
and we run
through achievement we run through
accomplishment we burn through
relationships and we are
parent always exhausted right
and then you said this
here's the other part
and this is a common thing with adhd
folks this this is a common thing with i
think adhd is one it's just a marker of
childhood chaos
um
you still have this fantasy that you're
holding out for
that
one day i'm going to call mom and dad
and they're going to say the right
things that mom and dads are supposed to
say when they have a sick grandkid or
when their daughter's exhausted
um even how you said um oh this is kind
of random but my grandma died
it's super not random
but when you're running from everything
you have to just let it it's like you're
sprinting and your buddy gets picked off
by the by the tiger you just you're like
uh well i gotta keep going
is that fair
yes it is it is and i i do get burned
out and there are times where it's like
i don't know like you're saying i'm not
tethered i'm i'm blowing freely in the
wind and i know people look around me
and i don't really know what normal is
but they're not running on my level and
they're like you know why do you need
this why do you act like that don't look
at me and are you okay what is okay i'm
fine i'm here and hey here's the other
thing
we live in a culture that rewards that
i can outwork you i can work longer than
you i can turn in better stuff and
quicker stuff and more aggressive stuff
and i can be louder and direct and cool
and great and super fun
and when i collapse that's on my own
time
and my paycheck goes up my promotions go
up
my performance goes up and inside
my body
i haven't changed the oil in 30 years
and eight years is a long time to be
lonely too as a 31 year old with two
little girls
and
i heard an attorney say this one so i
was working with some attorneys and
they
one of them said this and i had a friend
and she had the same exact experience
and here's my guess on you the attorney
we were talking about stuff and she said
or he said i feel like if i ever cried
if i just stopped and cried i would
never be able to stop
and my question to you is
if you ever just
stopped from it
and exhaled
and thought about grandma
and thought about five-year-old jennifer
standing between mom
and this complete buffoon of a human
and
nine-year-old jennifer wondering what
was so wrong with jennifer that mom
won't talk to me
and man i miss grandma
and again i miss grandma
if you ever slow down and sat in that
for a minute
or just as i'm explaining that tell me
what you're feeling
i'm flashing honestly to there's times
and um
you know i haven't found somebody you
know definitive to talk to and i guess
that's why i'm coming to you today
because listening to your podcast gives
some kind of clarity but i've had
moments in the last few months or years
even that um
you know it's like i'll be scrubbing the
bathroom and i start crying and i did i
i ran out it was like the anniversary of
my grandma died and i went and sat on
the porch for an hour and a half which
thankfully my kids weren't there so i
had the freedom to do that but there are
times where if i let it flow then it's
like i can't pull myself back out for a
couple days and i don't
i guess i just i need to but i i in my
head i can't afford to just sit and do
that because i have kids that depend on
me and don't understand you know all the
things that i've seen in my life and the
things i hope they never see and
so it's just hard i guess i'm gonna tell
you something but you're gonna have to
promise me
you have to promise that you're not
gonna internalize it
okay okay you promise
i promise say i put your hand over your
heart liar i'm just kidding
and then say i promise
i promise okay
our kids i'm a runner too
and that's i'm i'm trying to sound like
i'm all smart all those things i just
said it's because i live that
okay
i'm a runner big time
and
one of the most jarring and important
moments of my life was when i came to
realize that i can do things for my kids
and i can tell them things
but they absorb
that internal tension
they absorb it as though it is the blood
flowing through their veins
and they also see me smile concoct a
smile when inside my heart's racing a
thousand miles an hour because i'm
anxious and i didn't sleep last night
because i was thinking about this thing
that happened a long time ago and here i
go here we go here we go
and i they see me smile
and they see me make breakfast
and they feel
that's not him
there's a gap
and so what i would tell you is now
often when i'd say that somebody you're
gonna look in the mirror and internalize
it and say i'm a bad mom i screw i'm
screwing up my daughter it's the same
thing i'm recur i'm creating patterns
all that stuff
don't do that okay you are working so
hard all this is now is a matter of of
energy transference
okay
and you said you've got two daughters
that you got to take care of you got to
make sure they don't have x y and z the
greatest gift you can give them is a
vulnerable mom
is a mom that shows them what grieving
looks like
that when you cry they get to see that
and they get to see hey it's okay to cry
and then
we smile and then we go get ice cream or
then we all go for a walk or then we go
get up and do our next thing
because what happens is they're gonna
cry one day and they're gonna have no
model for it
something will happen as much as we
don't want something to happen to our
kids something will happen to our kids
and if they've never seen us do it
experience it be honest about it bring
them into that
they
it happens to them and they end up on an
island
and they think man my mom handled it
like that or dad was able to do this
and they don't know so the greatest gift
you can give your daughters
is
if they're young obviously you're not
going to tell them the full extent but
letting them know and tyler was really
hard it was hard growing up
and i miss my daddy and i really miss
grandma and sometimes i cry because i
miss grandma it makes me so so sad
um i've had a family member passed away
very very recently and the question i
asked my wife today when i was making
plane arrangements to go to the funeral
was i want to take one of my kids with
me
i want them to see that
um and so we're talking about how we get
them out of school and all this but
that's that's how important it has
become to me
so the greatest gift
hear me say this the greatest gift you
can give to your kid
is you
and what you're doing right now is
running as hard as you can so that
nobody can actually see you
they're trying you're trying to create
shiny things and markers and metals and
trophies so they can point to those
things because somewhere along the way
you got the message
that jennifer has very little value
and that to answer your original
question that's where the healing from
childhood trauma starts
that jennifer's got value warts and all
does that make sense
yeah and i know that's heavy right
so to answer your answer your original
original question in some detail dude
yes you for sure can heal
for sure
um
asking that question is step number one
step number two is the hardest thing for
somebody with a sick let me let's just
so let's
back up the aces score is not mine i
wish i was that smart i am not that
smart that's dr nadine burke harrison a
whole truck like trauma researchers that
came up with that um she's a brilliant
brilliant brain um but it's a 10 for
those who are listening it's a 10
question scale
that just rates childhood trauma and
what we know is if you have a four or
higher on this scale and it's everything
from
when you were in a household of divorce
did you see abuse does somebody that in
your immediate household go to jail did
you where you around addiction and
things like that
some things that we would think would be
benign or some things that when you add
them up it's this cumulative nature if
you have a four or higher it's when you
get into some really bizarre
correlations
cause causative correlations right not
even correlations or causation you see
an increase in cancers and you see an
increase in strokes an increase in heart
attacks things that you would never
like this happen as a kid and people get
cancer more that's weird and what
they're finding is our bodies stay in
these inflamed states for years and
years and years and years they're
fighting and running and freezing from
everything
and until we can
let our bodies know that right now we're
safe right now we're okay
it will continue to fight for us and
fight for us and fight for us and fight
for us year after year after year later
and that sounds like woo it's not in
fact the aces work the trauma work has
just been extraordinary
so step number one for you and this is
going to be the hardest one
when you grew up in an abusive
relationship or with neglect one of
those two narratives told you something
about relationships and your role in
them
does that make sense
yeah so if you're if you are abused
physically sexually if you are abused
you get a very clear message about your
worth
your body's worth your space in in the
world's worth
and you learn that people are not safe
or if you're neglected if mom is an
addict mom is going through her own
physical or mental health challenges you
are on the back burner all the time
she's too caught up in her new marriage
or she's she's an abuser whatever the
thing is if there's neglect
then the child gets a very clear message
that i am less than i don't have value
these other things are more important
than me and then kids will spend the
rest of their life trying to solve for
what was wrong with me
you had both
right
yes and so
the the really challenging part here is
the only thing that helps that healing
process is relationships and for someone
in your position those were the things
that hurt you
so my guess is you've tried have you
tried a counselor and you go once or
twice or you talk to a pastor or a
friend or once or twice and then you
bail out
yeah
i don't know if it's because if it's if
it's me making excuses or it just
doesn't line up or there's ones where
i've tried to you know hey let's unpack
the path and they're like well let's
just focus on right now or you know
let's let's not worry about your mom or
anything else so then i don't know i had
one tell me before that i was just born
and i needed to pick up an art class or
something so
oh man
see i was having a good time on this
show and now you got me all raged out
because i can't stand terrible
counselors no i'm just kidding it's not
you it's just i can't the courage it
takes to go see a counselor to go see a
psychologist
is so it takes so much courage to go
and if you get some nonsensical [ __ ]
like that that tells you things like
that
it makes my blood boil because you you
you can lose somebody and when you lose
somebody with two little kids you can
lose a generation
right that's why it's so important for
counselors to know in the world they're
doing that drives me crazy jennifer i'm
sorry on behalf of all therapists in the
country i'm sorry that happened to you
that should not have happened
um i would recommend looking for a
someone trained in
childhood trauma and a trauma therapist
in your local area
and
it will be expensive and it will be
worth every penny you pay for it
and i would let them know your past and
i would probably spend some time writing
this down
two or three or four or six or ten pages
however much comes out
but telling your story so that when you
get in that room you have so many
defense mechanisms and so many diversion
techniques to deal with relationships
it's how you've gotten this far
you'll be able to read it and say here's
what i'm dealing with
and here's who i need somebody to walk
alongside me
and
let's draw some connections to nowadays
but the answer is yes finding somebody
to talk to finding someone to walk
alongside and then you're going to begin
to
feel these things as they happen and
what will happen over time is you'll
drop the milk and you will feel it come
over your body and you'll instantly be
able to back out of it
and say what is this response
why is my body responding like this
that feels weird it's curiosity instead
of judgment right
and
slowly practicing that some of it will
be with trauma work whether that's emdr
whether that is
um you know somatic positioning there's
all these different ways that you can
work that trauma out of your body but
it's held up in there
and
some of it will be talking some of it
will be doing some hard trauma works
we'll be doing some writing some of it
will be doing some practicing
relationships maybe groups maybe taking
your daughters and doing x number of
things
some of it will be being really
vulnerable and it will be really scary
for you because vulnerability got you
hurt a lot right
yeah
and some of it will be meditation so you
can learn how to control your thoughts
so when they start to take over you can
walk it back and what i'll tell you
that's probably the part that you
believe the least and i'm telling you as
someone has walked this journey um
now it's just remarkable how you can
just back up i can back way up real
quick and that's just years of just
sitting and working in it
you're 31 my guess is if you make this a
priority and you say mom's gonna get
well
and i'm gonna raise two daughters who
are not only strong and powerful and
able to defend themselves
but who know how to laugh until their
guts hurt
and they know how to dance like bananas
and they know how to be strong and
negotiate and they know how to weep
bitterly and they know how to grieve i'm
going to reach those kind of daughters
because i'm going to learn those skills
so instead of thinking about this as a
you're broken and you gotta get fixed
think of this as i'm 31 i'm gonna spend
the next two three four years learning a
whole bunch of new skills
and in the process of learning those
skills your body will reconnect with
itself
and you will be able to sleep with no
medication
you'll be able to sleep without having
to scroll through instagram or watch
five netflix shows
you'll be able to date without worrying
am i good enough for this [ __ ] whatever
goofball sitting across from you it's
whatever table
and you'll be able to laugh
when you drop the milk instead of fall
apart does that sound like
how does it sound
that sounds well everything you
described is exactly me
but yeah that would that would be
incredible because you know i try but
there are times where i know i fall
short and i've i've made an effort to i
apologize to my kids anytime you know if
i get a short temper or you know my
patience runs out or something i always
come back and apologize and tell them
you know it's not you mommy loves you i
promise you know
i'm i'm working through or doing
whatever so i do try i probably don't do
it as much as i need to but i do try
even a little bit to be
vulnerable with them because i
only
an extraordinary
brave woman with an asus score of six
would turn forgiveness into a tally mark
or a performance
only
only jennifer not only jennifer only a
extraordinary powerful strong brilliant
woman who's got an asus grove six would
say
no i do i tell my daughters that um i
ask for their forgiveness and i tell
them i'm sorry but i could probably do
it better and i'll start working harder
at making forgiveness more of a thing
and i'm gonna make a chart and then
here's what i want jennifer to do
tonight okay
i want you to
number one before this week is over i
want you to have made a call and an
appointment with a
somebody in your area who specializes in
trauma
okay and you can google that you can
look at psychology today you can look at
any number of places you can have
somebody at work find a trauma counselor
in your area and i want you to go see
them
you don't have to go see them this week
but i want there to be something on the
books
the second thing i want you to do is i
want you to write a letter
to eight-year-old jennifer our
seven-year-old jennifer and start with
dear seven-year-old jennifer
my god you're so beautiful
and i want you to describe what she's
wearing
and then i want you to let her know
this isn't her fault
and it wasn't her job to defend mom it
wasn't her job to stand up to an abusive
husband it wasn't her fault that dad
left
and once you let that girl go play
she's still at she's still working and i
want you to let her know she can clock
out and go play
is that cool
yeah
i can be able to do that
yes do you promise absolutely i promise
all right hand over my heart you have to
i knew it liar i'm just kidding you're
not liar i don't know why i'm saying
call you a liar you're not liar at all
it just sounds like so dismissive and
ridiculous um when you write yourself
that letter don't send it but i you have
to this is the rules you gotta send a
note to kelly that said i did my
homework
okay cool
and after your first um after your first
appointment
i want you to write us back and let us
know how it went and it will probably be
rough especially if you write
write something that you can read to the
to the counselor there it's going to get
past all of your all of your weapons and
all of your diversion techniques and if
you are a person who's had an abusive
childhood or who's got a high ace of
score um you know exactly what i'm
talking about when you're walking to a
credit room and just direct traffic
because it keeps them from looking at
you
to anybody listening
number one recognize jennifer for the
brave soul that she is
if anyone else is for everyone listening
it is never too late to hear from heal
from trauma ever ever
ever
that's why i do the show it's never too
late 72 52 22
10. it's never too late to heal from
tama
ever and it starts with looking in the
mirror and saying
i'm losing control of my breath and my
sleep it's probably time i want
more for myself i want this is the magic
word
i want peace
jennifer you're
absolute rock star thanks for calling
and we'll walk alongside with you i hope
that we can stay connected for the next
year too as you walk through this
and i can't wait to
man i can't wait to
meet jennifer in person on the back end
of this when
she's going to bed with no medicine
getting up there's only one cup of
coffee it's gonna be great hey we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six-month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back jack let's go to i
don't know if there's a listener named
jack that'd be cool we are back
dennis and
i don't know that's our two listeners
dennis and jack i just made this weird
for dennis and jack out there hey dennis
and jack if you're listening
we're watching you all right let's go to
marie in harrisburg hey marie what's
going on
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm getting there getting there what's
going on yes
um i had called in um a couple weeks ago
regarding my daughter um
and
16 year old daughter
who was inpatient um at the hospital due
to a suicide attempt and we were waiting
to find a inpatient facility for her
um and you had helped me
kind of walk through that and what to
look for and who to ask and
screw up that helped a lot okay no no it
helped a lot
i appreciate it i was hoping you weren't
calling me to say like and you ruined
everything all right good
no
um
she is coming home from the facility
tomorrow um so that's exciting and we're
looking forward to having her home
but i know there's a lot of work that
we're going to be getting started on
um
two days ago i received a phone call
randomly from a detective
um
and i think the detective thought that i
was expecting the phone call or i was
given some kind of a warning but i
wasn't oh does she disclose abuse
yes she does oh man
she told that um i wasn't given any
details from the detective just that
there was abuse
and
then my mommy brain started going and i
called
a friend of hers
to see if she had ever mentioned
anything about it to try to get some
details
and um she did tell a friend
and the friend told me that it was
her cousin from the time she was about
three until she was nine
yeah
through very vivid details
um
hold on hold on hold on
do me a favor
take a real deep breath and hold it
and let it out
and take one more real real deep breath
and hold it
and then let it out
listen i'm so sorry
me too i'm so sorry that's your baby
girl and i'm so sorry
you didn't screw anything up
yet
no
if you murder somebody yes
don't do that
okay all right so dad and you are
divorced
yes okay um
we've co-parented for the past
tennis years no more than that probably
13 years
good or not good mature immature
[Applause]
it could be worse but it could be better
so it's not horrible okay it's
functioning um
yes
open communication okay all that jazz is
good um
it's like my 2006 truck it works it gets
me to work
but man but it's ugly
that was rude but you're correct
yeah i may or may not have all of my
headlights working yes okay right right
um
so after i got the phone with the
detective um i immediately called her
dead
and
um just gave him the overview that i had
and then after i talked to
my daughter's friend i then called her
dad back and explained what more i had
been told okay um the cousin is on the
dad's side of the family
lived with them for a period of time
and
dad is insistent that there's no way
this happened and she's lying okay
i don't think my daughter even knows
that we know
okay
and i'm not sure how to handle any of
this with her coming home tomorrow
i don't even know what to say to her
like i don't know if i start the
conversation if i wait for the
conversation i don't know how to live in
the same house with her without having
the conversation though um
and then do i prepare her
for the conversation with her dad
i
i don't know how to do any of this
oh man well number one thank you for
your trust
uh what a nightmare of a situation for
any parent at any time any place um
okay so before there is number one
um
the detective called you
so
let me just back out number one secrets
drown people
so
secrets are no good so yes we'll have to
have conversations yes we'll have to um
get into this and um ignoring it or just
letting her come home and like oh just
let her bring it up on her own time
can't do that okay
so keep that one that one
um that one put a pin in that note
secrets drown people
um she's been keeping these secrets for
a long long time
the second thing is
if there's
when she's discharged from the hospital
there should be some sort of
parent meeting with a social worker and
with a counselor a psychologist of some
sort is that happening tomorrow
we've already had that and they said
nothing
okay
the
um
the only
how old is she
16. okay so
sometimes in these clinical contexts
they will make agreements with the kids
when they're trying to work through
trauma with them
the reality is and i don't know every
state i know the states i've been in and
looked at licensure and has been a
professor and things like that
when you are when your child goes to
counseling the parent is technically the
client
meaning you have access to all records
all things discussed you have access to
everything
i can't imagine
a social worker not disclosing this
that's
bonkers to me
i know in the state of pennsylvania
where i'm located um
mental health records are sealed without
approval at the age of 14. so i don't
think unless my daughter were to give
permission that they can tell me
ah jeez okay
so
then here's the question here's a phone
call you make at 8 00 am tomorrow
morning
okay you call the social worker and say
i have been contacted by a detective
um i have talked to my daughter tell her
everything my daughter's friends okay
she's coming home i have active
knowledge of a family member who's um
done these things
and we need to circle up and have that
conversation
and really put the social worker on the
defensive now probably what she will do
or he will do and this is their license
this isn't them being evil they're doing
what their what their job is what their
licensure requires
is
i need to have a conversation with
my client
and let them know
and um
my guess is the young girl is ashamed
scared frightened that it's not a
statement on you that's a statement of a
scared child
and um
my guess is
she was asked and said i don't want to
tell anybody anything
and because she's a minor
i think man even even not even minors
anymore these these laws are changing so
fast in such really remarkable honest
awesome ways
but somebody had to report it to the
detective and the detective has
different rules than mental health
providers and so they have to contact
parents with a minor
all to say is going to get messy you're
going to have to be a bearer of a mom
and
bear meaning you got to go to war on
behalf of your daughter and the war here
is we all have to be in a room
communicating the same language
that's what the goal here is
if the social worker says the counselor
says i can't talk about it
then the conversation with your daughter
when she gets home
is um
lots of really
if she if she will again this is all pie
in the sky
um
less conversations for the first day or
so but
lots of hand-holding can we just watch a
show can we watch a movie together will
you cuddle with me will she do that
yeah okay yeah
what we're doing is we're looking to
establish physical safety first
okay all right and that's gonna come
through high touch high hugs hand holds
um
hugs hey will you sit by me whatever her
favorite food is let's just create a
safe place here at home
okay and if there is a
um if there is a friend if there is a is
there another adult she trusts or
something at some point very soon you'll
have to have that conversation
and it would go something like this
i got a call from a detective
and i learned some really troubling
heartbreaking things about how somebody
hurt you in the past
and i'm so so sorry and i also want to
honor the fact that you don't you're not
ready to talk to me about it
i want you to know that and does that
mean so i don't want you to put her in a
position where she goes on the defensive
again because she will
but i just want you to let her know i
know and when you're ready i'm ready to
have this conversation and then let her
know in the meantime and this is the
magic
in the meantime
i'm gonna go i have to go on the
offensive
because there's somebody out there that
hurt kids
that makes sense so it's letting a kid
know you can so what this sexual abuse
does is it takes control away from a kid
right
and the worst thing we can do to a kid
is to bring them back in a room in an
attempt to help them we take control
back from them again they feel out of
control and unrooted again
and
i have to make sure that this person who
did this never does this again
so when you're ready to talk to me i am
here i love you if you have any personal
experience with this
and you can connect in any way that this
is the moment to be vulnerable
um
if you haven't don't lie right don't
make something up right um here is the
the second cornerstone to put a pen at
number one secrets drown
number two
you have to believe your daughter
yes until you have every evidence in
front of you until you're holding
something that's that says she's not
telling the truth
and
i i
i understand your husband's fear and oh
my gosh what's this gonna do the family
and i understand that dead
that domino
you gotta believe your daughter
you gotta believe your daughter
and
the way we show our kids that we believe
them is we call the police we don't say
things like well let's just talk about
it and you know we call the police and
we work openly with the police we call
the school counselor we call somebody
that we're going to work with we let
them know
i am working on your behalf even if
their 16 year old little brain says i
want to keep this quiet
and it's so you hear the delicate
balance that i'm saying here
they get to wait to tell their story
but mom's going to work on your behalf
because i love you and my job is to keep
you safe i'm your parent yeah and i'm
not going to let that little scumbag
piece of trash that hurts you
i don't call me a piece of trash that
was that wasn't cool i don't i'm not
going to let that happen on my watch
anymore right does that make sense to
see that balance i'm we're in i know in
real time with a real human and a real
kid right in front of you this whole
thing's going to be feel wonky and
wobbly
and you may have to go back and say i
should have said it like this and i'm
sorry and i'm just so glad you're
maybe some walking about all that to say
is
physical safety lots of touch moms on
your side hey and mom knows
yeah and when you're ready i'm here okay
but i'm going to work
yeah and
um
at the same time be graceful with your
husband at the same time say no sir this
is our daughter and we're going to
believe it and we're going to
ex-husbands
you call that up quick xxx good job
um
i get the fear it's unacceptable
he's gonna believe his daughter
yeah
and if he's not um then he needs to
understand that these are these are
ramifications that go through
generations
i finally told that i wasn't okay and he
believed that guy not me
yeah
and that's hard and messy and gross and
weird and awful but here we go
um is the detective gonna do like a
forensic interview with her and go
through that process
yes but i have no idea when um when i
spoke with a detective she was just
trying to get
the jurisdiction of where
it was reported that this happened
um which was a very odd conversation
we're not we're talking about where it
happened we're not talking it just it
was it was it was a hard conversation
yes it can be surreal um
yeah yeah um but she really didn't give
me any information other than you'll be
hearing from the police at some point
okay and i've been waiting for that
phone call and i have no idea when
that's coming
do yourself a favor and your heart and
soul a favor
be ready for that call
but don't wait for every second you're
gonna make yourself crazy
right
um
when i sit down with my daughter and
have a conversation
do we do i then
call the police
if she wants
if she if she would want to talk to them
do we call them do
we just continue to wait to hear from
them like i don't know
i don't know how to handle that every
yeah if she's ready to talk then yeah
you call in everybody absolutely 100
if she says i'm ready to talk my guess
is she won't my guess is she went and
had to talk about it a lot and
therapy she's going to be embarrassed
that she calls all this stuff she's
going to want to know about the expense
of it all dad's going to bring up
expense this is really expensive i hope
that he's going to say stuff like that
because he's nervous enough to say
um
the main thing is reestablishing
connection here
if she said and how do you balance and
this is a hard balance that every
parent's got to deal with how do you
balance
i want to teach you and honor you and
your autonomy
and i got to do what i got to do because
i'm your parent
you know so
she may get sit down with the detective
and say nothing
i'm not gonna talk to you
the story that will remain with her is
mom called the police mom got me help
right okay and so we want that
established and
you can encourage her to talk to the
police you can
but at the end of the day you can't make
her or you end up forcing her in some
sort of
the arc is becomes really hard and i've
seen this happen over and over you will
tell them everything
well now suddenly i've taken from you
again
and that's the great fear when
somebody's been abused right is that
they were they were part of them was
stolen
and they were right back in the same
place
so i talked with a friend the other day
and she put it that this is her story
and i need to let her tell it correct
and
she's your daughter and it's time for
mama
to get after yeah
it's both and and when either parent
plays it on either side when a parent
tries to take over their kid's life and
say you're gonna do this you're gonna do
this you're gonna do this
it's a re-traumatization process not
always but often or when they just take
their foot off the brakes and they just
say she's just not ready she's 16.
you know what i mean like there's a
reason we don't let her buy beer because
her brain's not fully formed yet right
there's a reason we don't let her so
mom is supposed to advocate dad is
supposed to go to war everybody's
supposed to get involved to protect my
daughter
and these are the moments these these
pivotal moments when
maybe the right things aren't said but
the kid your child will remember mom had
my back mom was there by me okay and
let's let's play the other side of this
out
the worst case scenario is this actually
happened
that's the worst case scenario
it's also really going to be a mess if
she let's say she did make all this up
we will get there if we ever get there
but i'm gonna
default to believe in my kid until i
know otherwise yeah
even if that means we get to the end and
the detective says i don't have anything
that i can prosecute here i don't have
any text messages i don't i don't have
anything the stories whatever
she'll know mom mom had my back
yeah and i think it's worth telling your
ex-husband this is a pivotal moment in
in your daughter's life when she came to
us with something
she reached out oh there's been some
very colorful conversations i really
have i'm sure there have been i'm sure
there have yeah um
just remember secrets remember human
connection and remember believe your
daughter
okay and um if you have another woman
that you trust that your daughter trusts
it may be great to bring her in so i'm
gonna leave you with this one really
incredible story
um
my friend and it's something that i'll
do with my kid 100 and i've encouraged
people all over the country to do this
two of my closest friends in the world
guys named michael and a guy named kevin
and then we have another friend who's a
doctor they went camping and they have
they had kids and it was one of those
you hear these now there's no ritual for
for
uh western teens um to transition from
being a child to like we're gonna start
treating you with with some
responsibility and as an adult right we
don't have these moments these markers
anymore
so you hear about these things where you
take them out and you go on a camping
trip or something or a trip and unite
them you know like with a sword or
knighting or something like that
that's all fine whatever if that works
for you
they did something i've never heard
before and it was remarkable
they took
i think it was they took their sons out
maybe took out their daughter too
and they were at x age right so i'm
making this up let's say they were
turning 15.
they my friend kevin sat down
and handed michael's son
a card with his name and number on it
and he said from this point forward i'm
not mister and he gave his last name he
said i'm kevin
i'm going to start talking to you like
this and you're going to call me kevin
and
here's my promise in the middle of the
night dads aren't always the right guy
to call when you're too drunk to drive
home dads aren't always respond to the
best when you get that call from jail
like hey you can bail me out
so kevin looked at this his best
friend's son and said you call me
and i'll be there
and he said i will sit on your side of
the table when we talk to your dad
it's not we're getting we have to have
this conversation you went to jail right
or you got arrested or whatever whatever
but i'll sit on your side
and it was twofold number one it was
a demonstration to a young person here's
what friendship looks like even when
you're old
and most importantly some kids can't
talk to their parents this person's safe
and so if you have a woman two women two
three women who maybe have experience
here have had a history of abuse and
have are older now and have have healed
and are still healing
anybody in your life that you trust
that you bring into your daughter's life
and it's almost a passing of a torch i
know that i'm your mom and i know that i
can be loud and bonkers and whatever
she's safe and i want you to know if you
don't feel like you can talk to me you
can talk to her
and have that does that make sense so
there's almost there's this yeah not
almost there is a
there is a you're broadening your
daughter's safety circle you're you're
widening her debt
and
man
could be a really extraordinary gift for
your daughter
thank you for that call marie thank you
for calling back and updating us all on
the situation i'm heartbroken i'm glad
she's coming home
and i'm glad that she is still with us
i'm glad she is on the road to wellness
and
glad that she felt safe enough to talk
about this i'm heartbroken at what she
admitted
but
now we know
now we know
and now
the community's going to rally around
her starting
she's lucky lucky lucky to have you as
her mom
[Music]
we're with you holler back at us after
in a few weeks let us know how things
are going and we'd love to have you back
on the show marie thank you so much
we'll be right back on the doctor john
show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes you know like a
lightning bolt and i've been helping
folks 101 for years but i wanted to
create something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation and it's not really a
meditation but really just me walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish and i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise show you
how to lean in
listen and head towards healing it's
free and for everyone even you tough
hard chargers right you can download
this guided meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back um i got a quick
email here from kim
kim writes
i recently heard you say that you try
not to pay lip service to your
priorities but act on them
do you have any quick tips to ensure
that you're following through and not
just pretending
i'd love to have this person this
conversation in person kim but i'll do
my best to get at what i think your
question's about
um
any quick tips to ensure i'm not that
i'm following through and not just
pretending
number one i write my priorities down
i write them down i get them out of my
head and swirling around and i write
them down
some of them are
i
follow the data so i track my sleep i
track my heart rate variability i track
my diet with some regularity i track my
workouts with some regularity i've got a
gratitude journal so someone said i'm
writing down
i will move into i got some new journals
i'll move into a season of journaling
here um probably starting tomorrow where
i will begin to process some of this
stuff i haven't done that in a while so
i'll be i'll be doing some more writing
um this is in the middle of the night or
this is at night or this is in the
morning so some of it is just writing it
down
number two i talk about it i have a job
where if i show up somewhere and i've
been telling everybody to eat healthy
and i'm like hey i want some twinkies
and some pizza yeah yeah that's just
dumb right or if i tell everybody on the
show like to be respectful
and treat each other with dignity and
respect and then i'm out
you know being an idiot to the person
that you know at the drive-thru
um then i
so i put myself in a position where
people can hold me accountable for most
people this is your friend this is your
spouse this is your
like i've got with my kids like i told
my son the other day your room looks the
way it does because i've taught you that
like my room looks like is it like
this is on me so i'm going to make some
changes and i'm going to want you to
walk alongside me and i've got to own
that i modeled this for you
and dude we got to clean up around here
it's crazy
and so some of it is even some of my kid
might hold me accountable if i'm
vulnerable and i put it out that way
so number one write this stuff down put
it down number two
get people in your life that can hold
you accountable could be a coach it
could be a counselor it could be a
work colleague it could be a friend it's
about whoever that happens to be
and the third thing is
man
just do it
just do it we don't need another system
we don't need another 12 steps to just
do it
just get up and work out just
put as jacob says put the donut down
don't eat the pizza do whatever the
thing is
just don't
when you're about to swear at your wife
don't when you're about to flip the dude
off in the car because he cut you off
why would you give him that much power
in your life just don't
make a choice i'm not going to be angry
about this and i wish that was
more dramatic than that
it's not
just don't just stop and if you get to a
place where
i have a priority too and i just don't
feel like i don't care how you feel do
it do it anyway
for me doing it anyway starts writing it
down
but just do it and what you'll find
after five days 10 days 20 days 35 days
60 days 90 days
you just do it
you just do it and the drama and the
build up and i need just the right
planner with 111 ribbons in it and i
need just the right app and the just do
it just do it
man i think i'm going to start a tennis
shoe company and use that as the slogan
is that a good idea
no
100 100 bucks says nike sends us a cease
and desist letter
that'd be so good nike congratulations
you got a great slogan just do it all
right that's it as we wrap up today's
show hey
this song works perfect with that
james hands me these emails as we were
walking in
i'm not even gonna say the the name of
the song i'm not gonna say the uh oh no
actually kelly said me that last night i
didn't read it though that's just me
being honest to you and you handed it to
us there we go um
i'm not gonna read the the
author of this song
or the title
because we all know
here's the mystery song top 10 of all
time zach
prepare your body because it's going to
start moving
i didn't mean to say prepare your body
in that kind of way i know you're
already on the phone with hr i didn't
mean it like that i'm just saying like
you're about to start moving and
grooving that's all i'm saying austin
it's been a pleasure stay in school
don't do drugs all right here we go
here's the song
look
if you had one shot or one opportunity
to seize everything you ever wanted in
one moment would you capture it
or just let it slip
yo
his palms are sweaty knees weak arms are
heavy
there's vomit on a sweater already mom's
spaghetti he's nervous but on the
surface he looks calm and ready to drop
what bombs but he keeps on forgetting
what he wrote down and the whole quote
goes crowd goes so loud and he opens his
mouth but the words won't come out
he's choking now how
everybody's joking now the clock's run
out time's up over wow
snap back to reality oh there goes
gravity oh there goes rabbit he choked
he's so mad but he won't give up that
easy no he won't he knows his whole
backs to these ropes it don't matter
he's dope
we're all dope
you better lose yourself in the music
the moment you own it and you better
better
never let it go go
right here on the dr john delaney show